The problem we're having here is that we're not taking care of the quotes in the HTML markup.
Actually, anything that's within these quotes in HTML markup should not end HTML markup.
In particular, not the greater sign in here, so we need to extend a program appropriately.
The idea was as follows--rather than having two states, one for regular text
and one for HTML markup, we're going to have a third state,
which would handle anything that's within quotes.
Just as before, we start in a non-tag mode and when we see a less than sign, we go into tag mode.
This is what we do when we possess this very input and we stay in this mode until we find a quote--
that's when we go in quote mode and we stay in quote mode until we find another quote.
That's when we go back into tag mode, which happens right here.
When we see the greater sign, we exit tag mode and we possess the individual characters,
and we add them to the output.
Thus our output should now become foo as expected.
The remaining tag is processed just as before.
In order to implement this, we're going to use two variables--
one variable tag and one variable quote to indicate the three different states a program can be.